so for someone who's never cast a list
talent before and this could be for
either of you how would you suggest that
they go about it and I realize it's it's
not a matter of just pointing a finger
of who they want but in terms of getting
things through the proper channels
either if you feel inclined in the
inside it's funny cuz it's you know I
think having an a-list person involved
in a project somehow helps I think
obviously I've been lucky cuz you know
starting an SNL we're surrounded by it
and then you know see if I started
documentary now with with Bill Hader and
Fred Armisen and Seth Meyers and so that
helped obviously opened doors and then
obviously this project these guys took
it to Channing and he was on board as a
producer which you know again it
legitimizes you
it tells other a-list people that it's
okay to open that attachment and have a
look but but yeah I mean you guys might
wanna know more as writers um yeah it's
you it's usually a process generally you
know unless you're you're you know
personal friends with with the actor
then you usually go through a series of
you know initially probably go to their
company and I mean in the case of
Channing it was you know we brought it
to free association along with a 24 and
we pitched you know Peter Kiernan and
Reid Carolyn and and and essentially
they picked it up they just really liked
the idea and then we went in and talked
to Channing about it and he liked it as
well and that's uh then that
conversation led to us getting an a-list
director Thomas Nobu he was our he was
our collective first choice it's
completely true that never happens and
you know getting an actor attached is is
generally a great thing it can it can
constrain you because you need to have
the right person like for this Channing
was the perfect person so you know it
helps when when when the
and the actor or the talent really
aligned but yet it's generally a process
of it's a tough process yes you know I
mean I think anyone who's trying to get
anything made in Hollywood will tell you
I mean the most of what motivates
obviously what's getting made is the
attachment of stat you know that's where
your money comes from and guarantee
audience no like you know so it's like
they're everything is kind of riding on
that a lot of times we were lucky I
think in this show obviously because we
were basically go the actuals of you
know on the ground you know 12 13 hour
days shooting in the cold and all that
kind of stuff we didn't have to take any
lists people from but we had a list
Romanian actors there who you know so I
think you know they enjoyed the fact
that an American production was coming
and shooting in Romania and you know
they were wonderful but you know here we
had the added benefit that we were just
calling up people and saying hey can you
come you know being at the dubbing booth
for a few hours one afternoon and so it
makes life a little easier when you can
sort of ask further the less well I
think I read in the press notes where
you said that most the time in the u.s.
you're you know you're you're focused on
finding that celebrity but for the
Romanian part of it it was but there was
more freedom with that oh yeah yeah yeah
no it was amazing
to yet just to be able to go you know
it's almost like casting a play in you
know some in your local town and you
know with it like where you're just
looking for the who you imagine that
character to be and you know it was no
baggage of oh we want it to be a Ryan
Gosling type or anything like that's not
that you know it's it's you we were just
people walking in the room and you kind
of would immediately start having a
reaction of like is you know and you
know it was interesting because
obviously you know these guys you know
wrote these characters and we develop
them together and so it was interesting
also sort of getting to then see what we
all thought these characters were in the
process of meeting these Romanian actors
as they came in and so to understand
like oh okay you sir where was that time
okay and then I mean I really think like
probably like 90 99 %
I think we were all on the same page if
I don't think it was any little
disagreements about who we chose so yeah
it was it was a really fun like pure
casting experience yeah it was it was
great
if I could do everything this way and
dab it afterwards to get it made I would
do it because yeah it was great
you